[Musique]
bonjour je dis agen bonjour moïse
bonjour à toute la martinique secrétaire
général du parti progressiste
martiniquais merci d'être avec nous dans
son caddie les martiniquais johnny gens
ce qu'ils glisseront l'enveloppent dans
les urnes dans neuf jours pour le
premier tour des législatives veulent
savoir si les candidats désignés par
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
sont les meilleurs pour porter la voix
martiniquaise à l'assemblée nationale
les meilleurs parmi les 53 candidats
actuellement lis bien égouttés ici
ensemble martinique nouvelle et puis les
différents partis et mouvements qui
composent l'alliance se sont réunis et
ont réussi à trouver une entente pour
qu'il y ait justement un candidats par
circonscription
c'est parce que nous pensons que nous en
voyons les meilleurs de façon à faire en
sorte que la martinique soit défendu
dignement et que fort de france et
l'ensemble des circonscriptions du sud
du nord et du centre atlantique sans
véritablement avec des représentants qui
soit à la fois proche du peuple et avec
une capacité de proposition vis-à-vis de
l'assemblée nationale pour la martinique
sûr que le pmn ainsi que le ppm dont
vous êtes membres quand même subi l'ondé
de choc
emmanuel macron plus tôt affirmé que la
macro magna n'a pas eu de conséquences
dans vos familles politiques écoutent et
après c'est chacun qui voit midi à sa
porte nous n'avons pas eu de conséquence
serré sur la question parce qu'il n'y
avait pas d'affairé en macro les choses
soient claires il n'y avait pas du puits
seulement congé détails qui sont des
dramas kron a dû depuis qu'ils ont été
finalement des visionnaires parce qu'ils
ont misé su ils ont misé tout de suite
d'entrée sur le futur vainqueur de la
présidentielle pas du tout on n'est pas
derrière un cheval
d'accord je pense qu'on est déjà des
idées des valeurs la question de l'homme
vient après et la notion de groupe de
fidélité de loyauté est essentielle la
barre est d'abord aussi la question de
la défense des intérêts de la matinée
c'est ça qu'il faut porter au niveau de
la france il n'y a pas de problème
macron d'ailleurs aujourd'hui vous allez
voir un apaisement total sur la question
des présidentielles qui sont passés il
faut se concentrer sur les législatives
pour avoir des personnes dignes qui
puisse travailler en équipe parce que je
rappelle que un des buts et ne peut pas
travailler seuls
il faut pouvoir appartenir à différents
groupes il faut pouvoir porter des idées
des valeurs il faut voir les défendent
concrètement c'est une épine dans le
pied du président serge et chimie et du
bpm qui a choisi les perdants
successivement manuel valls
benoît hamon non pas du tout je le
répète c'est ducation de fidélité de
loyauté les valeurs l'éthique et la
moralité c'est la bo est essentielle
un élu doit pouvoir donner l'exemple
quand vous êtes fidèle et loyal peu
importe que vous avez vous n'allez pas
dire simplement celui qui pense pouvoir
gagner parce qu'aujourd'hui maquereau a
tout à prouver
il faut que nous soyons effectivement
lui donner sa chance qu'il puisse vous
faire ce qu'il a à faire parce qu'il est
élu démocratiquement
maintenant il ya aussi le parlement à
mettre en place parce que le président
de la république ne dirige pas seul il
dirigera avec le parlement serge les
cisailles et si par exemple il est élu
sera du côté des manuels macron sèche
jimmy sera du côté de la martinique
d'abord je rappelle qu'avant de soutenir
un candidat
nous faisons des propositions on la
refait on l'a fait aux différents
candidats action présenter à la
présidentielle
et c'est lorsque nous avons après
négociation obtenu des garanties que les
préconisations avec et social il va
s'asseoir à partir du groupe majoritaire
qui se mettra en place les différents
groupes on vire à en défendre là on a 70
mesures que l'on propose pour la
martinique pour développer pour investir
pour faire en sorte que l'homme puisse
ses paniers qui de l'activité sera due
si l'on veut souffler la tribune page et
tout ça c'est votre vision je serai en
question ce sera la défense des projets
pour la matinée que je pense qu'il faut
avoir une vision sur 30 ans pour la
matinée il suffit pas d'être élu
aujourd'hui est de diriger pendant cinq
ans ou d'appartenir à un groupe pour
dire je suis député l'idée c'est quelle
est la vision que l'on veut pour la
martinique dans 30 ans elle commence dès
aujourd'hui
donc il faut une équipe c'est pour ça
qu'il ya pas que serge letchimy il ya
une équipe autour de ses jets timmy avec
l'alliance mais peut avoir une équipe
plus large avec l'outre-mer et il peut y
avoir une équipe plus large avec une
base idéologique profonde de gauche de
façon à ce que l'humanisme et les
responsabilités prennent le dessus et à
partir de là nous déciderons de avec
quel groupe serge letchimy et les autres
siègeront rentrons dans le normand de
cette législative dernièrement sur nos
antennes de santé dit il y avait daniel
marie cette secrétaire national à
l'organisation du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais et il a dit
très clairement dans ce studio ici même
la mer
des batailles pour les patriots et fort
de france est ce que serge letchimy doit
redouter davantage d'adversaires francis
carroll qui est soutenu par le mime que
des failles en sable ça fait plus d'un
an et demi qu effectivement il ya des
attaques portées sur un homme qui
s'appelle serge letchimy qui ne le
méritent pas quelle vision pour se payer
que c'est de développer ce pays
mais aujourd'hui georges chimie c'est le
parti pour désistement et morizet 6h30
et le parti progressiste martiniquais
mais je vais vous dire quelque chose
c'est tout
tous les hommes et les femmes ont des
envies on a le droit d'avoir des envies
il faut dresser dans l'humilité et la
responsabilité le parti progressiste
martiniquais ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'elle subit ce genre d' attaques
multiples venant de toutes parts le fait
de la victoire la septième donne le
sentiment qu'avec le mensonge et la
manipulation
on peut aller conquérir à travers la
cité m
à travers une distribution massive
d'argent on peut aller conclut rire des
gens eh bien non on n'achète pas tenir
les siens se dit forcé son talent jamais
il est droit dans l'oeil en disant ça
qu'ils vont écouter ils ont gagné qui
centrait de rogner que ces rejets
chimiques en difficulté nous sommes dans
la sérénité
serge letchimy chez du tv n'a plus d'âme
à ce qu'ils disent comme très grave ce
qui se passe à fort de france ils disent
que c'est grave
vous savez ces questions ubm une gestion
nous ces rejets chimiques vous savez ce
qui est grave aujourd'hui c'est que la
ccm a menti sur le compte administratif
de la région vous savez ce qui est grave
c'est que la septième a menti sous le
fait qu'il n'y avait pas d'injonctions
de l'europe pour faire rouler le tcsp
que à cause de la 7e le tcsp bloqué
depuis un an et demi ça c'est grave
parce que c'est le peuple martiniquais
qui souffrent du fait qu'il n'ya pas de
politique publique il n'y a pas
d'investissement dans le pays que le
pays est à l'arrêt ça c'est grave
aujourd'hui nous sommes pas derrière des
postes il faut arrêter cette question de
coût yedaya les postes quand vous avez
un francis caron loin miguel laventure
qui sont à la fois conseiller municipal
conseiller communautaire conseil
exécutif depuis moins d'un an et demi
équivalent plus être député de la
matinée je pense qu'il faut un peu plus
de regrets que le jeu là ce sont des
cubes se sont de plus que des cumulards
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la capacité
d'assumer ses responsabilités place que
vous en savez qu'ils n'ont pas de cas
précis t4 une responsabilité éminente
quand francis quand le responsable du
personnel à la 7è 4000 personnes quand
il est responsable du social sous toute
la matinée que des organisations du
cidre oui c'est très simple à dire mais
vous savez aujourd'hui la loi sur le
cumul il a une obligation de
démissionner en tant que conseil
exécutif
mais je pense que le peuple a besoin
d'autre chose que des personnes qui
courent derrière des carrières
personnelles et des postes sachant que
vous savez que ces mêmes candidats la no
3 en viendront à la mairie de
fort-de-france
mais rassurez vous
anti progressiste martiniquais il serait
nous sommes dans la proximité avec le
peuple
nous sommes en train de nous renouveler
nous sommes en train de transmettre le
flambeau il a beaucoup de jeunes ya près
de 80% du comité national du parti
progressiste martiniquais qui a été
renouvelé avec beaucoup de femmes il ya
d'ailleurs plus de place plus de femmes
comité national du parti progressiste
martiniquais que d'hommes
donc nous sommes un travail de
transmission celle de formation et
réparation c'est pour ça que vous les
excusiez les hommes par exemple nous
n'avons exclu aucun homme suspendu vous
avez suspendu n'en ces personnes-là en
démissionner si leurs droits je prends
l'exemple de daniel robin il n'était ni
suspendu in any démissionnaire jacques
saint paul et ses responsabilités entier
match que vous mettez le penalty retiré
de la sphère daniel robin il me semble
que monsieur robin et surtout les médias
en tant que représentant dans marche
il s'est mis en congé il le système de
double appartenance a droit de cité au
parti progressiste martiniquais
il n'ya pas pour nous de double
appartenance il s'est mis en congé ça
veut dire qu'il n'est pas au parti
progressiste martiniquais à l'heure où
nous parlons maintenant nous allons
devoir nous réunir effectivement après
les élections vous discuté mais il n'est
pas en contravention avec le parti
progressiste martiniquais et comme il
n'est pas nécessaire du lkb non plus qui
coordinateur de la campagne de bruno
boudé les individualités ne peuvent pas
représenter l'adieu la direction du
parti progressiste nikkei la ligne
politique du parti progressiste
martiniquais qui est clair et qui est
partagé par tous aujourd'hui on est
royal à l'issue de ces élections non
nous parlons pas de nier
vous savez que vous êtes avec des êtres
humains des militants des sympathisants
la question n'est pas une question de
nettoyage la question restructure son
mari organisons par des fonds gelés dans
la réorganisation depuis un an
soyez un congrès maintenant depuis un an
et après 300 nouveaux militants parti
progressiste martiniquais
on a mis des futurs pour les accueillir
et les intégrer une vraie dynamique qui
se met en place avec beaucoup de jeunes
et aujourd'hui on est véritablement dans
l'espérance avec une vision politique et
un visionnaire que nous avons qu'il
s'agisse des méthodes qui sont
clairement définis par exemple lorsque
didier laguerre doit recevoir fred
lordinot ainsi que daniel chômé pour une
commission de dialogue c'est bien ça
c'est une commission de concertation
pour changer mais c'est lyon - union
pour cela disciplinera du tout ça n'est
pas une conseil de discipline le
président du conseil décide de 10 c'est
ce que disent les plaignants mai
vous même après écoute et vous avez
c'est la parole de l'un contre l'autre
mais avant une organisation très clair
et très transparente au parti
progressiste martiniquais comme ça avait
des décisions qui sont prises à
l'unanimité ou à une oeuvre de paix au
comité national c'est que les décisions
qu'on se sont partagés sur concertée et
la transparence et la démocratie au
parti progressiste martiniquais est
essentiel ce qui n'est pas le cas à la
7ème et pour la matinée une dernière
question très rapidement un 10 secondes
vous y pensez déjà aux sénatoriales
pas du tout nous sommes concentrés sur
cette bataille aujourd'hui qui est
législatif
il faut absolument regarder les
batailles les unes après les autres
sachant que je répète notre objectif si
l'investissement c'est l'épanouissement
de l'homme avec un grand h
et regardez la martinique de demain avec
véritablement la foi et la venue en
france serait bien merci johnny hazzard
d'avoir est avec nous rappelle que vous
êtes le secrétaire général du parti
progressiste martiniquais bonne journée
merci